the mayor of Pittsburgh calls it the
darkest day in this city's history I was
at that vigil last night it was
heartwarming and heartbreaking at the
same time so many people gathering to
mourn the loss there now this Pittsburgh
neighborhood is home to more than one
quarter of the city's nearly 50,000
Jewish community stars of David's with
the names of the 11 people who died
lined the sidewalk behind me as you can
see there the suspect who is
hospitalized will face a federal
magistrate later today authorities have
issued multiple search warrants
including at the suspects Pennsylvania
home David beg no is here with more on
this investigation David good morning
good morning it's a clump complex crime
scene inside right it's gonna take
police tell us about a week to process
inside of the synagogue there are three
different congregations and all of them
were worshipping when that man walked in
and opened fire investigators have been
working around the clock to learn more
about 46 year-old Robert Bowers
and exactly how he planned his alleged
assault inside The Tree of Life
synagogue he had no criminal record and
was unknown to police ever since he
moved in it's been it's been shot Chris
Hall who is Bauer's neighbor says Bowers
worked as a truck driver they never saw
his name printed anywhere here my
landlord tells me he paid in cash for
rent on a website that is popular with
the alt-right Bowers posted a photo of
three handguns that he called his Glock
family and he wrote Jews are the
children of Satan Bowers was also
fixated on a group called the Hebrew
immigrant Aid Society or Hayase
they help refugees settle in the u.s. in
his last post before the shooting Bowers
wrote highest likes to bring invaders in
that kill our people I can't sit by and
watch my people get slaughtered screw
your optics I'm going in armed with an
ar-15 style assault weapon and three
handguns
police say Bowers opened fire shortly
before 10:00 a.m. on the synagogue's
main floor and then he went downstairs
eventually killing 11 people and
wounding six others minutes later
officers encountered him at the
entrance bowers went back into the
building before being shot and wounded
by the SWAT team he surrendered about 20
minutes after the rampage began
expressing hate even as he was in
custody a lot of people have asked that
this is a case of domestic terrorism can
you speak to them there's no indication
that he's working with anyone else and
so we have charged it and are treating
it as a hate crime so this morning the
suspects being treated at the Allegheny
General Hospital and we spoke to the
president who says that the suspect kept
yelling kill all the Jews even while he
was at the hospital and in the ambulance
and bianna the president of the hospital
says the irony is the nurse who's
treating the suspect is Jewish so many
people in this city regardless of their
religion and background have a
connection to this story and so many
wondering why why our city why did this
happen to us David thank you